nobody pull a hamstring the thing about
time travel I can't believe I made a
whole movie with this thing I look
cooler doesn't feel cool but if it looks
cool as ice you have any idea what's
coursing through my veins right now
Funyuns yes we are getting the whole
team aren't we
[Music]
see that the dough over ten years
you
hi everyone happy Comic Con week they
finally dropped the Avengers end game
bloopers in gag grill there's a whole
bunch of deleted scenes they broke up in
here too so I'll explain what's going on
we're also doing that Avengers end game
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Marvel phase 4 or avengers
endgame moment on the video I'll name a
new winner at the end of this there's
about 15 or 16 different deleted scenes
that they packed onto this but it starts
with a warm-up your buttcheeks moment
that's a few part of the scene of
everyone getting ready for the charge in
the final Avengers Assemble scene when
Captain America finally says the whole
phrase after three almost moments of
saying the phrase he actually said it
during Avengers age of Ultron right at
the end but Joss Whedon edited it so
that it cut straight to the credits
right before he said it if you watch the
gag reel from age of Ultron you can
actually see Black Widow jump in front
of Chris Evans and try to say it to
Avengers speaking of Black Widow this is
from when Black Widow and Hawkeye are
traveling on the guardianship to Vermeer
definitely not like Budapest like we
said the Black Widow movie is basically
covering all that Budapest stuff I'll
post a link to my Black Widow trailer
breakdown from Comic Con at the end of
this this is Rocket's nightmare come
true thank you very much thick Thor or
the Lebowski Thor Iron Man breaking the
tesseract prop in the basement of that
shield base from Captain America Winter
Soldier if it wasn't clear when they go
back to the 1970s if that shield base
you get that awesome Stan Lee cameo who
also has an appearance in this may he
rest in peace
the underground bunker that they used
the elevator to enter with the Yvette
Nicole Brown community cameo no less is
the bunker from Winter Soldier where
they go down and they see Arnim Zola
who's uploaded himself into the computer
Yvette Nicole Brown was actually the
second community cameo during the movie
Kenji Ong was the manager of the
warehouse where Scott Lang's van was
being stored earlier and it is can do
felt kind of weird in almost a little
too silly for the way they played it or
out of place somehow he was actually
supposed to have a cameo during Avengers
infinity war but he had a scheduling
conflict so they just brought him back
for Avengers end game if you're not a
longtime Russo brothers fan the reason
why there are so many community cameos
in all of their Marvel movies is because
a long time ago they got their start
directing television episodes community
was one of the last really big shows
that they did before they made the jump
to doing really big Marvel movies for
Scarlet Witch can barely walk this is
from the scene where she just totally
hooks out on Thanos and he almost winds
up killing half of his army just to stop
her this is from that epically huge
deleted scene of everyone battle
planning in the trenches after Doctor
Strange portals all the other characters
onto the battlefield the scene would
have originally come before the Avengers
Assemble scene but they felt like it
just completely slowed the third-act way
down too much so it's why in the
theatrical cut that we all saw in the
movie theaters everyone portals in and
then they just go straight to the
Avengers Assemble charge we're cap calls
the hammer back even though it is really
fun to see these extra scenes I do feel
like the way that they cut it works
better like they portal in then they
charge they don't hit the pause button
on the battle and then go run off to a
trench and talk to each other then have
the big charge love the scene of Chris
Evans just totally making fun of his
Captain America outfit from the first
Avengers film when he's talking about
this helmet I can't believe I made a
whole movie wearing this helmet he is
talking about the actual filming of the
original Avengers movie way back in 2012
there's a long documented history of him
hating that helmet and the reason why he
hated it so much is because his ears
were covered and when he was wearing it
on set he couldn't hear anything that
anyone was saying not the directors not
the actors and it almost made it
impossible for him to film with it so
when they got to Captain America Winter
Soldier they fixed the problem by just
removing the parts of the helmet that
covered his ears so that's why the newer
versions of the Captain America helmet
don't have those ear pieces on it
this is just from a bunch of alternate
takes of war machine making fun of thick
Thor not being able to stand him there
were a whole bunch of alternate lines to
each of these scenes too particularly
Iron Man Robert Downey jr. scenes that's
why they posted this other funny deleted
scene moment of him preparing for scene
in the Avengers based it's just him
trying a couple different versions of a
scene yelling at everyone jokingly not
to give him notes
I mean let's see how this first one good
anyone says cut say to my face where I
can see you they kind of do the same
thing with Tom Holland when he's filming
his spider-man big battle scenes they
don't give him a script because of
security reasons they're worried that
he's gonna give away big spoilers but
they'll just give him an idea for what
they want in the scene and just have him
try different versions til they get what
they want from the scene this is part of
that deleted scene with Hulk in the
ancient one they changed some of her
dialogue when she explains how the
Infinity stones affect the flow of time
in the original version of the scene
they didn't have any of that
explainer later on they added the bit
about the Infinity stones creating
branch realities just to make it clear
why Captain America had to bring them
back at the end of the movie and set up
the plot twist for tesseract Loki to go
off into his Marvel phase for series
remember they finally confirmed at the
big Marvel phase four panel that the
Loki that we'll see during that is the
version that escaped during Avengers
endgame with the tesseract creating an
alternate reality love Iron Man dropping
all the f-bombs he can because the trunk
in the Audi e-tron that they're using is
just closing automatically in the middle
of their scene and he can't get it to
stop this Black Widow scene is from
Vermeer when Thanos came from 2014 with
the outriders to attack her and Hawkeye
to stop them from taking the soul stone
this is even more of that really big
deleted scene of them charging out of
the trenches after they decided how they
were going to attack daños this is a
deleted scene from Iron Man and The
Avengers inside the Avengers base during
the planning phase of them figuring out
where all the Infinity stones are
located and which time periods they need
to go back to this is from Black Widows
final scene on for Mia right before they
filmed her death scene like saying
goodbye to Jeremy Renner and all the
crew members like all right waving
goodbye I'll see you guys in the Black
Widow movie even though that's set
during the past this is more than talita
scene of her fighting Thanos and the
outriders with Hawkeye on Vermeer that
was actually a pretty big part of the
film as Jeremy Renner says they
completely changed it because it was way
too complicated and they didn't want to
spend extra money to have an extra
battle on Vermeer this as you would
probably guess is Iron Man right after
they filmed his death scene with Pepper
Potts and spider-man
come up and she says you can rest now
Tony we're going to be okay this is a
deleted scene of Iron Man and Pepper
Potts at their lake house when the
Avengers come for the first time to get
his help and he invites them to stay for
lunch as long as you don't talk shop you
can stay for lunch presumably in this
version of the scene Pepper Potts just
freaks out a little like wait a minute
we have all the Avengers over for lunch
they're getting ready to drop the
Avengers end game Home Video in blu-ray
release so there's a whole bunch of
other bonus features deleted scenes in
extra long scenes I'll do breakdown in
Easter Egg videos for all that stuff in
the next week or so but there's a lot of
it and there's still a lot of other
comic-con Marvel phase 4 and other
videos that I'm working on so leave all
your video requests in the comments
below but there's a lot of really good
stuff coming up next big video will be
my Batman hush video and then a Thor for
love and thunder breakdown
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video de France
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here for my blade reboot Marvel phase 4
teaser breakdown from Comic Con and
click here for my Black Widow Comic Con
trailer footage breakdown thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]